how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything mcu and today is a great
day because we have some
exclusive one division details coming
from entertainment weekly
there are a lot of reveals in this new
issue of entertainment weekly focusing
on one
vision that i'll be sure to go over
including new photos for the one
division series and a lot of commentary
about some of the episodes of one
division from kevin feige elizabeth
olsen
paul bettany and some of the writers and
producers as well
including some talk about how wanda is
going to fully transform into the
scarlet witch by the end of the series
and how the series is going to directly
lead into doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness specifically the
scarlet witch will make her appearance
in the multiverse of madness there's a
lot of great information in this article
so if you don't have access to it don't
worry i've got you covered so i'll break
it all down but first i'm doing a new
giveaway and partnered with
heroeshideout.com
and from now through december till the
end of the holidays i'll be giving away
one item each week from marvel funko
pops to marvel legends action figures
all you have to do to enter subscribe to
my channel like this video leave a
comment down below and check out heroes
hideout.com
so the first thing we'll dive into
before getting into some details about
the wanavision series and episodes that
they filmed are
new pictures now the first one that we
got is obviously the cover photo for
this issue of entertainment weekly it
has wanda
and vision on front of it and wanda is
half color
half black and white which we know the
show is going to start off in black and
white and then gradually become color as
time goes by
just like sitcoms have done over the
years and the title says
the wanda years after dominating the box
office marvel is ready to take over tv
here comes wanda vision now this is just
a cover photo but we do have
six new images from actual episodes of
the series and we'll start off with this
first one which is kind of
odd but most of the show seems like it
is going to be rather odd which is
awesome
but it's of wanda and vision and as we
can see here they are sleeping
in separated beds now this is kind of
done for two reasons one
is that with the old sitcoms it was
actually illegal to show them
sleeping in the same bed it was illegal
for them to show that on tv
now this kind of just further adds to
the weirdness of their relationship but
if you look at wanda she's looking a
little bit confused now we know this is
going to involve
different realities so it's almost like
wanda just woke up
and was randomly in this room with
vision it's either that or she has
noticed something weird or she has heard
something and it doesn't all make sense
and if you take a look at the shadows on
the wall between the beds of wanda and
vision we can see a shadow that kind of
looks like a witch's hat now of course
this is just a shadow from the bedpost
but this is also most likely a reference
to
witchcraft we know agatha harkness is
involved and we know that there's going
to be witchcraft in the show
and for those who might think this is
digging a little bit too deep marvel has
actually already done this with their
first promotional art for the one
division series if we take a look at the
two of them sitting on the couch holding
hands if you look in the upper left hand
corner you can see both of their shadows
and while wanda and vision are sitting
on the couch in human form you can see
in the upper left-hand corner their
shadows are of their superhero forms we
can see vision as an android and we can
see the scarlet witch in her full
scarlet witch costume and speaking of
witches the next photo is of catherine
han's mysterious character
called agnes now again it's pretty much
confirmed that she
is in fact agatha harkness after all
agnes is just agatha
and harkness combined to make one word
but she'll also be playing the unusual
nosy neighbor and in this photo it looks
like she came over to give the couple a
pineapple or to borrow one either way
it's kind of weird
now the next photo is actually a very
important photo it's of wanda
pregnant now the important part of this
photo is one not only does it confirm
that wanda is going to be pregnant and
will indeed have kids which
has already been confirmed but the
second part is look at their faces they
both look to be an extreme confusement
and this is most likely because
wanda is going to randomly get pregnant
in the comics it happens out of nowhere
vision doesn't
actually give wand a kid she just
becomes pregnant and that is especially
true if you consider the fact that
they're sleeping in separate beds in the
show but they do look
very confused in this scene and vision
is reaching out to touch her stomach
almost like i can't believe it how did
this even happen
this almost definitely confirms that
mephisto is going to be in the one
division series and he is the one
responsible for wanda getting pregnant
this is a page right out of the comics
where wanda gets impregnated by magic
and we would go on to find that her two
children are actually the shards of the
demon mephisto
and ultimately he would take them back
and her children would be gone and this
is what eventually led to her kind of
losing her mind
and creating the house of m reality
where magneto ruled the world
now the rest of the photos are kind of
just fun photos there's one envision
leading over the kitchen counter
looking at each other smiling you can
tell that they're really happy there's
wanda envision inside the kitchen again
and wanda has a weird expression on her
face
perhaps performing some type of magic
and then the last one with a
very confused look on her face and she
is indeed performing magic using her
powers to cook
it looks like she's preparing dinner and
something really ticked her off or
surprised her
now there's a lot of commentary about
the show that gives us some pretty big
reveal so let's break it down
for starters it has been confirmed that
the first episode of the wanna vision
series was in fact filmed in front of a
live
audience something that marvel studios
has never done before
now to start it off we actually get kind
of a little synopsis about the show
and the synopsis reads as follows set
after end game the series starts with
the married witch
and android living in the idyllic town
of west view
we find wanda envision living a blissful
suburban existence
trying to keep their powers under wraps
but as the newly weds cycle through the
decades and the familiar tv tropes they
realize their white picket fence life
may not be as gleamingly picture perfect
as it seems
now you have to remember that with the
first teaser that we got for the one
division series they most likely just
showed us the first episode or first
couple of episodes we know and it's
confirmed right here that the one
division series is going to go through
the decades
very very quickly tayonna paris who is
going to be playing monica rambo said
that this is going to be an
action-packed tv series and we know
we're really not going to get that in
these tv sitcom type of eras so we're
going to go through and get out of these
sitcom eras pretty quickly as they said
as they cycle through the decades that
means their kids are going to grow up
very fast as well now another huge thing
that has been revealed by this article
that has been speculated for a very long
time is that we are going to see wanda
fully explore the scarlet witch and the
scarlet witch's powers
she has yet to be called the scarlet
witch and it has been confirmed they are
going to indeed call her that in this
series at one point
and she has yet to discover her full
powers but that is going to change in
this series
the article says one division promised a
chance to explore wanda's past and the
full
capabilities of her telekinetic powers
in initial conversations about the show
feige won her over by referencing
specific scarlet witch
comic story lines although she won't
reveal which ones
due to spoilers then it quotes elizabeth
olsen saying it's been the biggest gift
that marvel's given me getting to do
this show
you get to just focus on her and not how
she felt through everyone else's story
lines so it's all about wanda and the
scarlet witch and although they say they
can't reference the comic book
storylines we pretty much know that a
good chunk of the tv series is going to
be based off of the house of
m storyline and i actually did a video
not too long ago
explaining all the comics that one
division is going to be based off of and
i'll link that down below and put it up
above
but the great news is we're going to see
the scarlet witch and her
full powers in this show now mary
lovanos who is a co-producer of the show
says it's really incredible to be able
to tell a long form story
the way the comics did in a sense a tv
show is a multiple
issue comic book run which is something
that from the marvel development side we
totally do
understand so this is really really cool
because in a way we're going to get a
more
comic like tv show than we've ever
gotten before and it was explained in
this ew
article that this is very different from
the netflix marvel shows and
agents of shield because kevin feige had
complete creative control over these
series so this
is full mcu these are basically going to
be movies packed into one hour long
episodes in fact tayonna paris who is
playing monica rambo says
i was like oh i thought we were doing a
little show but no it's six
marvel movies packed into what they're
presenting as a sitcom
so disney plus really is giving us
marvel fans a very
unique and awesome opportunity instead
of just getting one two hour film we're
getting
six one hour episodes that's going to be
like six different movies packed into
one season
and hopefully there will be multiple
seasons and to top it all off
ew says in their article ideally marvel
hopes
one division will be just the pilot
episode of a long-running tv dynasty
the studio is already hard at work
developing seven additional shows
with each one connecting to past and
future films
one division kevin feige notes will
directly set up the 2022 film
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness with olson's witch
playing a key role alongside benedict
cumberbatch as sorcerer
and notice how they specifically said
elizabeth olsen's
witch that means by the end of the one
division series leading right up to
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness she is going to be
a fool scarlet witch with her full
powers so we are definitely
in for a treat with the one division
series it sounds like it's going to be
absolutely insane which i love
and it sounds like wanda is definitely
going to become one of the most
strongest characters in the entire
marvel cinematic universe if she wasn't
already
so let me know what you think about all
these reveals from this ew article
and also of the new photos that we got
as well let me know in the comments what
you're most excited about for the
wanavision series
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all of the latest
marvel news
give the video a like if you enjoyed it
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof